Donald Trump is the sixth President to
visit as rumors Richard Nixon was the
first in 1974 Jimmy Carter Bill Clinton
George W Bush and Barack Obama also
traveled to the country as present
dancing or is co-founder of the foreign
policy initiative
he's also co-author of startup nation
the story of Israel's economic miracle
and a plan Mitt Romney's trip to Israel
during the 2012 campaign
welcome to B whether you gotta love that
let's just talk about what exact
happened in Saudi Arabia sir first there
is in the Middle East is great Sunni
Shia split and beyond speaking to these
people who were there in Saudi Arabia
there's nothing he could have said to
them that would have pleased them more
than trying to isolate Iran because it
was a direct contradiction of what
Barack Obama is trying to do the
centerpiece of much of President Obama's
foreign policy in the Middle East for
his eight years was figuring out if
there was a deal to be done with Iran
Iran could be a potential partner in the
region that had the effect of in the
eyes of this of the Gulf two Sunni Gulf
countries of which Saudi Arabia is the
most powerful that he was downgrading
their relationships and they were deeply
uneasy about this and for the present
nighted States on his first trip abroad
to come to Riyadh and basically say we
are in this together
we are here to isolate Iran we're going
to work with the Saudi the Sunni
countries we're going to work with
Israel and announcing this big arms deal
with Saudi Arabia really sends a message
about it till you saw the Iranian
Foreign Minister in the last 24 hours
tweet out sort of lashing out at what
President Trump had done in Saudi Arabia
it's a clear sign that the Iranians are
worried about the potential isolation
which is and what he hopes it's the
Saudi Arabia in those other countries
will help him with Israel doing some
deal with the Palestinians right in
other words if Israel is to feel that
there's space to get some kind of done
deal done with the Palestinians they
want to know that it will also include
some kind of normalization of
relationships with the broader Arab
world and that has never come before and
I think pred the Trump administration is
trying to push the the Sunni Gulf states
in that direction he never mentioned the
word radical Islamic terrorism something
that he mentioned quite often on the
campaign did that surprise you at all no
because he look I we've seen a number of
cases where he says a lot of things in
the campaign and he can read [ __ ] for
for governing and he had to do
here because he had secured some pretty
considerable concessions from the Saudis
and cannot just they were working
together close in Iran which was an easy
you know deal for the Saudis to make but
in combating radical terrorism covering
the ideology behind it combating the
funding behind it there was one very
significant step that was that was
accomplished on this trip they got the
Saudi to not just say that we as a
government will not support the
indoctrination and the funding of
terrorist you know activities around the
world we will bar citizens from doing
its citizens will be held criminal
criminally liable which is which is a
big big thing development the symbolism
of this trip very important as well
believed to be the first direct flight
ever from Riyadh to Israel what does
president Trump want or what will he get
in this visit to Israel yeah so it's so
it's the first time a president has gone
this early to Israel and in the
presidency right you mentioned all those
other presidents none of them have gone
this early Obama and Bush went during
their second terms I I think that the
president wants to send a message to
Israel we have your back you are not
alone lock arms with us I mean this is
the thinking of a national security team
lock arms with us and if he can get
Israel to lock arms with the United
States and make them feel that the bond
is unbreakable that we have your back
that you can trust us Israel be more
comfortable making concessions taking
some risks for peace if they otherwise
would not hit and he's also saying that
Israel and these Sunni Arabs have the
same enemy which is Iran and we'll help
you there absolutely so let's let's
unify and isolate this together I said
the strategist I gotta go I would just
say the the Sunni Arab world in Israel
have been quietly working together the
last few years this is a new development
this they're quietly working together
and I think the Trump administration
wants that to be sort of not held
beneath the table but above the table
held very publicly had a new
relationship thank you thank you so much